[MUSIC PLAYING]
GAURAV JETLY: OK, good
afternoon, everyone.
Thank you for joining
the session here.
And I believe you must be
exhausted, specifically
after the fantastic
lunch you guys had,
and everywhere on the park,
wherever you go and see.
And I just heard there
are some beers also
from the garden side.
So a couple of rules.
Please open your recliner
and you can relax, sit down,
because I think we will take
you some journey of Kronos.
And I think what we're going
to show you here is definitely
in a very high level synopsis--
talking about
Kronos, what we are.
I'm sure you guys
know us, but we
play into a niche
area of the market.
Well, I think we'd
like to explain that.
And then also talk
about our journey
in the Google Cloud three years
back, and when we chose Google.
And I'll appreciate,
in case you guys have
any question in the middle,
feel free to ask and come
to the podium and speak
here, because they're trying
to record every question.
And if you cannot, let me know.
I will try to repeat it for you.
So some highlight about Kronos--
we have been in the market
for close to 41 years now.
A Massachusetts-based
organization close to--
we serve plus 40
million employees.
I know if we were talking
about billions, everything what
we see in Google, what they do.
And we have close to 40 million,
and across all 100 countries,
represent 31 location
across Kronos
and cater Fortune 500
companies leveraging Kronos,
and also our partners
who leverage Kronos.
We have a various workforce
management offering
and human capital
offering, which kind of
attaches every nimble
area of office management,
from timekeeping to human
resources to labor analytics,
and to the scheduling area.
So in short, any area which
touches the labor productivity
index, specifically from any
vertical, in any organization
across the world.
And I know when I saw
a lot of registration,
there are lot of
customers who are here--
including Google-- using Kronos
and our various offerings
what we have.
So we will talk about, I
think, these are the key areas
or domains which Kronos serves.
But we'll talk about our
next-generation offering, which
we kind of built
on our 41 years'
experience and the input from
you guys-- from the customers.
And I'm sure when
I say you guys,
I will see a lot of other
people coming in soon here.
So I would like to give
you some analysis here.
So we are not new in cloud.
We started our cloud
journey around 2006.
We have today 24,000
customers in our cloud, which
is on one of our
legacy offering,
which is Workforce
Central domain.
And 90% of all our SaaS
deals are on cloud.
So I think the experience
of running in a cloud--
the cloud SaaS business
I think exists in Kronos,
so that transformation happened
for us a long time back.
What I think the cloud-native,
where the next-generation
of cloud-- where we
say the product built
in purely cloud-nativeness.
We started our journey
almost four years back,
and I think that is where
the birth of Dimension.
And I believe if you have
seen our CEO, Aron Ain,
speaking about the core
named project, Falcon--
which had a big story, which
I don't want to cover here,
not to bore you guys--
what we started.
So three and a half
years, four years back,
one of the key
goals our CEO said,
make Kronos out of the business.
He was looking for a
next-generation SaaS offering,
which is purely cloud-native,
which is purely SaaS,
but also thinking about the
future of workforce management,
keeping in view customers-- what
customers think about Kronos.
We have loyal customers running
from Kronos from 25, 30 years
and if we want to build the
next-generation SaaS offering,
what areas of interest--
what areas or opportunities
for customers, for us, we
would like to make into it?
So I think on the verge of that
the birth of Dimensions, which
is our next-generation SaaS
offering which went live
this year, went ahead.
And I think we have close
to 70-plus customers
during the implementation
phase, and we
have close to six, seven
customers already live,
well-served, trading on
a Google Cloud, doing it.
It's almost for a year now.
So the basic of
Dimension-- and I
think I would like to give
you a very high level,
then I will try to take
you deep down in each area,
just to give you some overview
of that birth of Dimensions
with respect to our
customers' experience--
what customers look for us.
So if you in a very
simple way understand,
the customers for our
product are basically
three areas of people.
There is a manager in
an organization who
wants to make sure that he can
manage the labor productivity
level in terms of
roster and timekeeping.
And there is a user itself
where-- all of us, we
use time and attendance.
You want to punch it, use
those biometrics time sheets.
How can an employee
experience change?
And then I think
the IT team itself--
those organizations
who are sitting inside,
and everything is
going cloud-native--
they're challenged
at how they can
integrate the entire
back office systems
and make it more effective.
That is a big
challenge, actually.
Everyone wants to go cloud,
but the internal cloud, IT team
still have some
legacy applications.
So some people are far
ahead, like Google.
They are the first one.
But there are some
people or organizations
who are last, who are dealing
with on-prems, versus hybrid,
versus multicloud,
and I believe you guys
heard that loud and clear
in all your sessions.
So our journey will
go into that part.
And keeping all these
areas of interest,
keeping our
customers investment,
I think we want to build
this revolutionary workforce
management experience,
which we call Dimensions.
And then I think we will
also talk about that
how partnering with
Google, what gave Kronos,
and why Dimensions carries
a different experience which
we already have,
and how we leverage
our experience with working
with you as the customer.
We added some features.
And for sure, I
think I'm not going
to talk something
new about it, but I'm
going to talk about the
artificial intelligence,
the machine learning, and then
also the cloud platform-- how
we are leveraging it
from Google and building
this next-generation offering
by enhancing the customer user
experience.
So I think we
started this project
with a simple
experiment, as I said,
with managers, with employees,
and with IT organizations.
Managers want to make sure
that they have less time,
and they have a
lot of team members
to manage with
their routine task,
with their
timekeeping schedules.
And think about
different verticals.
Think about
hospitality vertical,
think about the
retail vertical, thing
about the IT technical
vertical, or public sectors.
Large organization enterprises,
when managers are just
working still on time
sheets, rostering
sheets, the manual way--
how can we enhance
their experience?
And then the employees
I spoke about,
where employees
want to make sure
that when they need time off,
and they need their rostering,
it's all available to them.
And the amount of
time which is being
wasted in getting
those things processed
when the manager
doesn't have time--
how we can plan that out?
And then IT.
And I think we thought,
how can we innovate,
again, these features?
How cool it would be
that if a manager,
he can drastically reduce his
time by automatically the time
key, the sheet, the
rostering at the labor level
can be automatically
done for him?
How can we analyze the
data which exists for him,
and can be predictive, by
giving him recommendations?
How can we have
an employee where,
when he is submitting
for a time off,
it can be automatically
approved when
we know what shift
pattern he does
and how they are
managing it out?
And then for sure, I think
the foundation principle--
which I believe,
which Google has
been trying to teach us from
the last two or three days.
How can you leverage
the foundation principle
of the APIs, the foundation
principle of the integrations,
and the data which you have by
creating a cluster computing
framework which can govern
the responses for you-- which
can give an organization
like IT teams
their integration services
where they can hook this
with any back office system
without even thinking about it,
which normally today becomes
a big project in our existing
world?
And we'll talk about this areas.
I'm not trying to intentionally
give a high level,
but starting the areas of
opportunities and key interests
we look into.
And for sure, when you get
into a cloud-native business,
the entire high availability,
entire global deployment,
entire supportability
comes by default with that.
So I'll give you
a simple example.
Take a very simple example.
We built a Workforce
Advisor which automatically
detects an employee--
his name is Michael--
his routine decision
that if I am Michael,
and I'm submitting my time card,
that should automatically get
approved.
Why it has to go to manager?
Why manager should waste
his time approving it
when the inline algorithm and
inline policy already mentioned
that that employee has
dates, has times available,
and it could be approved.
So how could you increase
the productivity level
for the entire organization,
which can talk into the labor
resource, and that can talk
into billions and billions
depending upon the size of
organization what you manage.
And we are using
this combination
by using the artificial
intelligence and the business
rule, which I believe, A, we
have from our experience of 41
years, plus working
with you as a partner,
and then leveraging the inline
technology what we are trying
to leverage and build out.
There is a very big difference
when I will come and talk
about a very high
level Dimension
architecture, the
approach we want to use
when we build with Google.
That will differentiate a
little bit the way people do it
with cloud-native versus the
way Kronos took an approach.
Then also, I think we
also thought about, one
of the key areas is how you--
data is everywhere.
I believe the best
part which Google
has done, how they can
forecast and display
their data analytically to
us, where you see fun facts.
They're processing
300 billions of data.
It exists, but I think
how people are presenting
that out is the game here.
So in our business-- in a
workforce management business,
if you can forecast
and predict that I
have labor
productivity available,
and I know what are the areas of
concern in one of the sections,
and I know that if the
time keeping and I know
the productivity index
is not going fine,
and then your data can predict
and give you those forecast
ratios when you're
trying to plan out,
I think that is what you need.
And I think that is
what the new featuring
forecasting solution we
added, which predicts the user
experience.
We have tools available
which will tell you,
based on the customer, their
vertical, their location,
how can you provide the
index, which can give you
the improvement efficiencies.
For sure I think, as I
said, the cloud-native
brings some fundamental
foundation principles.
So we reformed the
entire UI for Dimension.
The world is changing where
nowadays and app drives
the behavior, rather than
you click on app, you know,
like Facebook, LinkedIn,
or any other model.
Even if you see Google Console,
I think the way they drive it.
So part of our UI--
I think we totally reformed
the UI where it is purely
cloud-native, and it has a
way where, when you log in--
so there are days when you
want an analytical data.
So we are trying to bring the
entire UI by bringing the chart
and tiles which displays
your analytic behavior, which
are so agnostic and responsive,
where any location, any device,
any way you use, it will
give you that information.
And all the information is
available up front for you.
Rather than getting into
the app and driving it out,
an app will drive it
to you, and telling you
that whether you have
a time off request,
whether how many time off.
So you can build your
analytical index up front
on the UI, itself, which is I
think really cool, because now
you have a real-time engine
which is running along
with the real-time services and
giving you all that display.
And the software is becoming
more intuitive, too.
And again, for
sure, as I said, it
comes with the
embedded analytics.
We are trying to upfront
bring those information there
which are configurable, where
you can bank the amount of data
based on your organization,
based on your personas--
whether you are a manager,
whether you are an employee,
or you are an IT organization,
you can hook to it.
And I think you
don't need to get
into the any data warehousing
solution, any ETLs.
Everything is upfront,
available in a real-time way.
So I think those who understand
Kronos domain think about one
of the examples where you wanted
to understand the totalization,
understand the reporting
index, understand
the integrations of your
payrolls working overs,
when you get into more
workforce management domains.
Everything is available at your
UI where you can manage it all.
And then, for sure,
I think then I
want to give you
another perspective.
We saw the manager.
We saw the employees, where
employees can decide what
is the schedule's best format.
I just want to
give a glance here.
Think about one of the
employees like Howard,
who would like to
understand which location
he wants to work on--
would like to understand
what shifts he can
offer him, if he
wants to make a shift change.
Today in the world everything
is very process-driven,
where the workflow goes
to the manager approval,
and if manager is not available,
then whether it will happen
or not.
But in this case
scenario, I have
written if, as long as you
have the rules defined,
the Advisor can give you
those recommendations.
An employee has an
ability to choose and pick
based on the rules and
configuration defined,
which can happen automatically.
So I think the power of
leveraging the workforce
management system by a user
experience from an employee,
I think can be enhanced, and you
can reduce your unwanted time
which he is leveraging and
waiting for those approvals.
And that could be leveraged
towards better productivity
level, and I'm sure enhancing
the employee engagement, too.
And we have been working
with the key areas--
leveraging the AI and
the machine learning,
and I will talk about how we
are doing it in the example.
So again, picking one
of the common examples,
I think nowadays
people pick Tesla,
but I thought of
picking Nest, here,
because that resonates
with Google standing here.
So like the way Nest has changed
the market-- when you deploy
Nest, everyone knows,
it reads a pattern,
understands your
behavior, and then
sets the algorithm
where it automatically
runs the thermostat
or any security system
where you leverage
it to learn that.
And I think this is a
similar kind of a behavior,
a user experience
we want to bring
into workforce management.
We know the history.
We've been working with you.
You've been using
Kronos products.
How can we do it differently?
By-- we can learn
from the history.
Based on the data and reasoning,
provide recommendations--
like employee time off,
rosterings, scheduling,
analytic-- where a product
is driving these behaviors.
And the artificial
intelligence can easily
solve this problem, which
technically humans can't do.
So example-- like, I can
walk an afternoon shift.
When someone is not available,
you can automatically see that,
and they can normally decide
which person is available,
who wants to do, and you can put
your priorities in and decide
the shift pattern without
any managers being
engaged to manage that part.
Trust me, when you go
into a different vertical,
like manufacturing, which has
shift [? shots ?] running,
and at the manufacturing plant
such thing as a huge labor
[INAUDIBLE] problem.
And even if you go to the
hospitality sector, also.
Even if you go to, like,
hospitals, you will find this.
So these are key areas
depending upon the domain
and the verticals you play in.
The artificial intelligence is
the way we are trying to cover,
and the machine learning
we are trying to do
is technically providing
the right forecast accuracy
to the system, making
sure that the algorithm
work we are projecting is for
a customer perspective only.
So for example, a
question can come in mind
that when you're trying to
do the machine learning,
is it per customer
perspective or you're
aggregating the entire layer?
Because when you talk about
artificial intelligence,
machine learning can be an
aggregation for everything
or per customer basis.
So we have specifically built
our algorithms focusing on
per customer layer where we
can depict your customer,
your vertical, your
behavior patterns,
the way you use the system,
and it can advise you
based on that subject to,
you are a manager employee,
and how you can manage that out.
So your decisions are smart,
and it will allow your manager
to be a manager, rather
than acting and doing
those services where he should
not be wasting his time in.
And the glimpse-- what you
see is a real-time use case.
We're kind of a showing where
you can see the employee labor
index, depicting on patterns
from a monthly layer
of volumes, labor,
and the maintenance.
Because these are numbers.
People are money.
The most expensive [INAUDIBLE]
in any organization--
you can talk about tools,
technology, infrastructure--
I think it is a resource.
So I think the art
of managing resource
with an intelligent way, I
think that is what the job we
leverage by leveraging
our experience
and working with the customers.
And then for sure,
coming and leveraging
the technology
which is provided.
So now we call it as D5 because
we have five elements which
define the dimensions.
So for sure software
as a services.
I should be a fool
if I say that.
Third dimension is a pure
microservices SaaS-based
architecture, where our
platform for services
is a D5 area, API
and integration.
So seldomly we've been
asked from a customer,
how can I use my data?
How can I integrate my data
with my third-party services?
And again I have a SQL
where I can run-- you know,
if you talk about legacy
ways of running the software.
So we thought, why don't we
build an open-API platform
where we make customers' data
available in the public API,
which every tenant can
consume in a secure way.
And for that I think we used
one of the key elements which
Google provided to
us by using Apigee.
So we leverage Apigee
as an on-prem software,
and we build a solution
along with dimensions
where we provide
customers an ability
to have public APIs where
they can consume their data,
whether it is the
reporting function,
it's an integration function,
or it is a customized function,
which they want to do.
So that level of
data is available
so that they can get
the data out and hook it
to any of the CRM system, and
make their back office system
and IT system more efficient.
The artificial intelligence,
by building out our own cluster
computing framework, by using
known technologies available,
we are trying to seed
individual customer data
playing through the algorithms
by understanding and creating
the workforce advisory mechanism
to depict those behaviors
for the customers, whether
it is decision-based
or whether it is based
on the AI language of 100
commands of human
layer by ingesting that
and documenting those behaviors.
Then along with the
in-memory computing,
we are also predicting
the analytical layer.
So if you are
punching it here, you
have an ability to have
real-time analytic display
within the UI itself.
So those days have gone when
you are running an ETL--
and I know in for Google,
in front of sounds new.
But we still have
legacy software
that does that, where you have
over 12 hours of ETL running
and the data is coming.
You have real-time analytics
[? bay ?] where you can do.
And we leverage that by
leveraging the computing
power available from a Google
when we use their GCP platform.
So I think the benefits here--
that it's an open
platform, it's predictive,
it processes large
volumes of data
by leveraging GCP compute
platform available,
which provides us--
it manages the adaptive
rules and suite interaction,
which we build with
our algorithms,
and then also it
unifies the data access.
Where the information
access is available,
we will work for a
designer for you,
where you can create
your own business flow
to accept that information.
And as I said, this
platform from API,
we call as an API gateway.
We build the entire
Dimensions architecture,
very heavily built on one of
the secret principle of flaws,
which is throttling
and guard railings.
Because when you build a
multi-tenant architecture,
you want to make sure that
every customer data is secure,
protected.
There are no noisy
neighbor configurations.
So Apigee plays a big and
important tool for us.
We are not only externally
publishing the API,
it's including even internally.
We make sure that the whole
ecosystem talks via that way
so we can control that.
And in case a customer
requires, there's
a further customization of API.
They are possible
where we can leverage
the same process
of certification
to launch that for them.
I think in a simple way, it's a
modern cloud with a robust API
framework, built on an
artificial intelligence,
for sure using the
blazing-fast in-memory compute,
which comes from inline
compute platform from Google.
I think one of the
key areas-- and I
will talk about Google
also highlighting
when we leverage
one of the areas,
and the reason we come here.
And then I think the
flexible domain model
what we built, built on a pure
microservice architecture where
every technology has a domain
model which allows us to fetch
the data by leveraging the
API then presenting it out,
whether in a public APIs way
or in a business workflow
information available
on the product itself.
Which is totally, I would
say, a big transformation
from Kronos from
Workforce center 17 years,
41 years in the market, from
an on-prem, to a hosted model,
to a pure SaaS
native-cloud built model.
And I think that
is where Dimensions
is our next transformation
business where we are.
Now I think one of the
business objectives,
we want to make
sure that consumers
can have-- it's a fantastic,
great experience for you guys.
You can work anywhere,
any device, whatever
you want, purely UI responsive.
You can collaborative
scheduling your timekeeping
for salaried employees, which
is duration based, project
based, or network time based.
It can be very well managed.
And then we can meet any
industry-specific requirement,
which we cater.
And I think based on the
experience what we have.
Any questions?
I'm sure you feel free to ask
any question what you want,
but then I want to come
to the important part.
One of the key elements
when we chose Google--
and I will tell you
right now I used
to say that to Veronica,
to Jason, and to Shane
and other people when
we started Google--
I can write a thesis on that,
because when I chose Google
three years back with the team,
everyone was asking about,
why Google, why not Amazon?
I would say I think one
of the reasons, when
we chose we were in a
transformation phase,
and we really
needed a partner who
can tell us that, how can
we see the bigger picture
rather than going back to our
world of host in private cloud,
how you do the business-- how
a cloud-native work is looking
in the model, how they can
work and partner with us
my understanding of the model.
And we are actually very--
I would not say I think we are
different, because now Google
has so many customers.
I used to say that.
That is kind of an old.
We kind of build a
platform-agnostic architecture,
and today in Google we
just use the GCP layer
within [INAUDIBLE].
Thus, everything is a
platform-agnostic model
that we have built.
And I think I would say
it's a kind of a use case,
where people who think that
Google just have container,
you come and build
container-- no,
you should think like kernel--
there's an enterprise who comes
with a pure [? private ?] cloud
experience, redesigned
the platform
with the next generation
offering as a greenfield,
built GCP and the native
services from infrastructure,
and wrote our own
architecture by leveraging
the entire cloud-nativeness.
And I think that is where,
as an example-- and I believe
we learned a lot.
Google learned a
lot, and we were
in this journey from
the last three years
where I think we have
complemented each other.
And today we stand
where, I'll tell you--
I could say that we are
live, it's been one year.
But we have been
live three years.
I have 6,000 people
using Google in Kronos.
We have literally, if
I count internally,
close to more than a million
employees in the system.
We have close to
4,000, 5,000 tenants
internally being
leveraged by engining
and our internal organizations.
And then we have
literally 80 customers
in the implementation,
and close to six,
seven customers live,
and I think every week
and every hour I
will say, they're
in the progress where
we are signing in.
So I think the
overall experience
in terms of-- for sure
I think for the context,
it is the best fiber-class
network security perspective.
In terms of cost to the
business, it's great.
But I would say I think
it's a partnership.
When we needed Google, I
got everyone available.
It's not like you have
to go to Diane Greene.
At the end of the day, I think
it's the people and engineers
who work.
I think everyone was available
from an executive layer
to the Google technical
layer, and I believe
they are really smart guys.
When you talk to them--
and one of the stars,
she's just joining.
She is late, but I excuse her.
And I think we are on this
transformation business,
and I think we are
still not done.
Every year when we come
here, our eyes got opened.
OK, we thought we
are doing great.
We're are on the
SaaS first, but when
Google shows us,
here is the next five
years where you will go.
So we tied them again, and
focused on projects again
where, how can we
improve the services.
And at the end of the day,
it is for our customers.
I think what we have
to learn from Google,
that even though Kronos was
small and Google was big,
they gave us that level
of support to understand,
and I think that's what
we are trying to learn.
There are also customers--
like, be the customer,
customer's consciousness,
customer experience, and
the opportunity drivers.
And then we should partner up
by leveraging the technology
and build it out.
So to me, I think standing today
here I could say very firmly,
and I feel proud that three
years back the decision
we made, and today where
we are with Google journey.
And I can tell you, like,
three hours back I had
10 [INAUDIBLE] I was seeing.
Today Google Cloud is
everywhere, you know?
It's getting [? short ?] of it.
So the experience for
Kronos, I think, overall
from our engining, we
build our software there
and we build software
in a very different way,
by challenging even Google.
There are some times
that-- how can you leverage
this infrastructure to build?
And then we also have
customers running--
large customers
running in a system,
where not only here I would
tell you customers running from
an international location
hosted in the US with fantastic
latencies--
fantastic response time.
So I think our experience
has been great,
and I think we are
on the learning curve
by learning from our
customers sitting here,
and then also learning from
Google by getting more inputs.
So it has been a
fantastic journey.
I would like to thank
all the Google, plus also
all the customers
who have been patient
and are giving us
this opportunity.
You don't get an opportunity
to redo a software again
and again.
It's a lifetime opportunity.
So I'll pause.
I know we've finished.
We have time for questions.
I would still request
if you can ask here.
If you can't, I don't
want to bother you.
If you are in a
recliner, you're open,
I can take your questions.
AUDIENCE: So when is
this infrastructure
going to be available for
smaller organizations,
like from your
Workforce Ready product?
This is D5, is that right?
GAURAV JETLY: That is correct.
AUDIENCE: Is there a roadmap
or plan for those users
using Workforce Ready?
GAURAV JETLY: Absolutely.
So part of this offering, we
chose [INAUDIBLE]---- in fact,
I don't know whether Veronica
asked you this question,
because she is asking me every
time when Ready is coming
to Google.
So just to repeat a
question, so Workforce Ready
is one of our requisition--
[INAUDIBLE] is another
product, which is fantastic,
which is for our small and
medium industry scale--
not hosted in Google,
but a SaaS product,
does pretty well in business.
So part of the transformation--
our approach was that--
you have to understand,
an enterprise company
coming to public cloud
world three years back,
I can't tell you how I have
to convince my executive
to be there, but I
think they accepted.
So we have a success path here
with damage in the building
out in Google by leveraging
the platform-agnostic model,
and it's already
in our pipelines
where soon we'll be
leveraging the same for Ready.
From a customer perspective,
whether you use Google or not,
what you see is the
product available.
But I think we already
have work in progress,
and very soon you will see it
will be available there, too.
From our perspective,
I think we don't
want to get into the
infrastructure business.
We want to focus on
our domain business,
and enhance user experience.
And these guys are spending
billions of dollars.
Let them do it, and
give us that service.
So I think we have a
successful Dimension,
and we want to carry
on with others also.
So soon you should
see it will be coming.
It's already on the pipeline.
[MUSIC PLAYING]